okay so as I told you a lot of people  really liked the Jenga contest we did  the Jenga tower after falling and  generating the great coupon code Jenga  58 is now back intact on the desk with  me just off-camera for for camera one  which is over here but it is still with  me and we have a really funny conspiracy  video that was put together by spike  fence I get that it's satirical but it's  really funny and it relates to the  conspiracy of the falling Jenga tower  check this out thanks to spike fence for  putting this together  Oh No that's it  Oh No  [Music]  [Music]  that's a whole other thing which I'm  going to be performing just for paddle  and an interpretive backing objectively  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]